[MUSIC PLAYING]
YOLANDA MANGOLINI: My
name's Yolanda Mangolini,
and I lead the Global
Diversity and Inclusion
function at Google.
I've been at Google
for 11 years.
And while I started my
career in financial services
and management consulting, I
consider myself a firm part
of a technology industry.
I'm really proud and
excited to be here today.
It's a special day, not just
because of this amazing panel.
But because it's
International Women's Day,
a day when many
women-- yes, nice round
of applause-- but it's a day
when my fellow women and men
in the tech world are
honoring and celebrating
the millions of women who
came before us in the hope
of creating a better world.
I want to honor this day by
having a discussion with some
of the most interesting and
trailblazing leaders in tech
today.
There's been a lot
of research on--
I've been in the diversity
space about seven years.
And over that time, I've
seen a lot of research
around the importance of
diverse and inclusive teams.
It affects the
degree of innovation
that you have, and even
affects our bottom line.
But while meaningful
change is possible ,
there are a lot of challenges.
There are a lot of
barriers that we face.
So we have assembled
an incredible panel
of five change-makers
here today,
to share their stories and
advice on some of the ways
that the tech industry
has been driving success
through more heterogeneous work
and inclusive environments.
And I will let them
introduce themselves.
We'll start with Bridget.
BRIDGET FREY: I'm Bridget Frey,
and I'm the CTO at Redfin.
JEANETTE CALANDRA: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I'm Jeanette Calandra with
PricewaterhouseCoopers.
I manage our Silicon
Valley and San Jose
practice, where we have a
team of about 1,300 partners
and staff providing a variety
of professional services
and tax accounting,
management, and IT
consulting to the leading
companies in the Bay
Area, many of which are tech.
So in my role as a
managing partner,
I work very closely with our
national and local diversity
leaders really to create
that environment of inclusion
for the many diverse
staff that we have.
I think it's really unique that
we have over 65% minorities
representing our
office in San Jose.
So our minorities are
truly our majority.
So that presents some
interesting opportunities
as well as challenges.
And lastly on the personal
front, I'm a mom of two.
And I've been working on a part
time schedule for the last 10
years, and continue to do so
in my various leadership roles.
So thank you.
I'm really honored to
be here today, and be
with this wonderful
group of women.
YOLANDA MANGOLINI:
Thank you for coming.
Sowmya.
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: Hi,
I'm Sowmya Subramanian.
And I'm at YouTube, Google,
Director of Engineering
there, running our
YouTube music efforts.
And have been at Google--
this is my 11th year.
Never thought I'd be
there for this long.
But I am there.
And partly because I think
it's just a great environment.
Have been able to do a lot
of things within the company.
Which almost feel
small startups that
have grown into bigger efforts.
So I was involved in founding
YouTube Kids, YouTube Live
Streaming, and now I'm fully
focused on making YouTube
Music and YouTube
Red subscription
that we launched
successful and meaningful.
And I'm really
excited to be here.
I do a lot with women
in media as well,
just to change the perception
of how women are portrayed.
Whether it's in technology roles
or just stereotypical roles,
both women and men.
And it's really fascinating to
see how much we can do there.
CAROLINE TSAY: Hi, everyone.
My name is Caroline Tsay.
I recently started a company
in the enterprise cloud
infrastructure SaaS space.
I actually haven't looked back.
But prior to my
company, I was at HP.
I used to run the online
channel for software.
So anything to do with
marketing and selling
our enterprise software online
was what I was focused on.
That was an interesting
journey in my career
because I was able to
start a whole new business,
a whole new organization,
and a new platform going
into HP, which, most people
know, is a large enterprise.
Prior to that, I was at Yahoo,
in search and e-commerce,
and had built teams
there as well.
Now it's just a whole
different perspective,
starting a company, fundraising
going through that process,
and thinking about talent
and inclusion and diversity.
So I'm really excited
to be here to share
the different perspectives.
AARTHI RAMAMURTHY: Gotcha.
Very similar here.
So my name is Aarthi
Ramamurthy, and I'm
the founder and CEO of Lumoid.
Lumoid is a Y Combinator
backed startup.
We have an office here
and one in New York.
What we do is try
before you buy service
for consumer electronics.
Think of it as Airbnb
or Rent the Runway but
for gadgets like drones,
photography gear,
wearable fitness trackers,
things like that.
And prior to that, I
worked at Microsoft,
worked on Xbox and
Xbox Live, catering
to billions of customers there.
And then worked at Netflix,
millions of customers there.
So it's been a
really radical shift
to start thinking
about it as how
do you cater to a totally
different audience,
different scale of
audience, and also
deal with building your
own company from scratch,
similar to what
Caroline had said.
And how do you think
about diversity,
and how do you scale the
team and grow as you think
about diversity and inclusion.
So it's been a really
fun and interesting ride.
And it's great to be here,
happy Women's Day to everyone.
YOLANDA MANGOLINI: I can see
we have an incredible wealth
of experience on this panel.
But let's get right to the
question that's probably
on a lot of people's
minds when it comes
to diversity and inclusion.
As women who are
leaders in technology,
do you think the environment
in Silicon Valley
has gotten worse or better
over the past few years?
And are you optimistic
about the future
for women in our industry?
Anyone can respond.
BRIDGET FREY: So
early in my career,
there were a lot of
situations where I
was the only woman in the room.
So for example, when I
was an intern at Motorola,
I worked on a floor
of 150 engineers.
And there were only two women,
me and the group assistant.
So we had an entire bathroom
with a lounge and couch
all to ourselves.
But other than that, there
were very few advantages
to that situation.
And so I think it
has really changed.
The numbers, I
think, are improving.
At Redfin, we now have about
30% of our software engineers
are women.
And I think even
more importantly,
the number of women have
been able to communicate
with each other
and compare notes.
So back when I was
at Motorola, there
was no Twitter to hear
other people's stories.
There was no Google
Spreadsheets where you could
collect data and compare notes.
And so I'm just seeing a
lot of increasing advocacy
where women are coming
together and saying,
what's it like for you.
Here's what it's like for me.
And then use that data
to advocate for change.
JEANETTE CALANDRA:
Yeah, it's funny.
I think Silicon Valley gets
a pretty bad rap for this.
And I would say being
out here for the last 10,
12 years is that I really
have seen a big shift.
And that's whether
it's in PWC specific
or when we're out at our
clients and at the boards.
So I remember a
similar experience
when I first came
out here in 2005.
Very few females
or diverse partners
in our San Jose office.
And I remember that
they had put together
some internal
marketing material that
was meant to be kind of
something beneficial, right?
It was like highlighting
the women of San Jose.
And when you really looked
through it, first of all,
the number of partners
versus other senior managers
or other managers was
very far and few between.
And then in the bios, when
they kind of went through
and you kind of start looking
at the few female partners
that there were, one,
weren't too diverse, and two,
they were either unmarried
or they had this little thing
about my husband
stayed at home at work
to take care of the kids.
And so this wasn't
really inspiring
as a career focused
a woman, who had
a partner at the time who was
very focused on his career
as well.
And so looking kind of what has
happened in the last 10 years,
now we're really proud
to share that if you
look at our last couple of
incoming partner classes,
we're 30% women now.
We're 43% minorities.
We still have a ways to go.
Because when you
kind of match that
up to the people who are
coming in to the pipeline, who
are starting with
the firm, we're
much more diverse at the
in part of the funnel.
But we're getting much better.
And then even on
the client side,
I mean, you go into
these meetings out here
and you'd be the only
female in the room.
And now I love it, I go
into some meetings and all
of a sudden, it's all women.
And you go, OK, wait.
Who-- does anyone letting
the men in here, right?
And you're seeing those same
trends at the board as well.
So really promising, I think.
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: I
think mine is very, very
similar to Bridget's, actually.
When I started, I
used to be-- it just
would be very common
to be the only woman
in the room as an engineer.
And one of the things
that I see has changed
a lot in the last 15
years in the industry
is there are so many more women.
And just many more different
types of people, not just
women.
From different backgrounds,
different countries,
different languages,
who are actually there
at the engineering level
when you look around.
So I think that's been
a huge shift, which
is really nice to see.
I must say, though,
I think there's still
a lot more we could be doing
at the leadership level.
It's great to hear
stats like yours.
But I don't know
that that's the norm.
Like in technology, for
instance, yes, some of us
are here.
We founded companies
and are CTOs.
But I do feel that it's again
the next phase, where when you
get to that leadership
level, you many times
are the only woman
in the room again.
And that's where I think there's
an opportunity to change.
The other good change
that has happened,
the shift that has happened,
is it seems much more
open and OK to talk about it.
Like we're having
a panel like this.
Which I don't know
such a panel would
have happened at the next cloud
conference or Oracle OpenWorld.
Right?
Talking about how do
we change culture.
And I think that's
a huge step forward.
CAROLINE TSAY:
Yeah, I completely
agree with Sowmya on
the point that there's
a lot of visibility into things,
or lots of research studies.
It's a much more
open conversation.
But I think too
many times now, I've
still seen that slide
that says here's
the number of this, this
type of demographic,
this type of background.
And it's talked about, but not
much has been done about it.
So you know, I think it's
drawing that line between what
are we seeing progressing and
changing in terms of diversity
of backgrounds, demographics,
skill sets, experiences,
thought.
This is something that's talked
quite a bit at the board level.
I sit on two public
company boards.
Something we talk
about all the time.
But ultimately, you know, it is
up to you, I think each of us,
to take some kind of action
to make that progress.
AARTHI RAMAMURTHY: Speaking
from a startup's perspective,
I think for a larger
company, larger companies,
I think there's some
pressure to have a specific--
diversity is important,
inclusions is important.
There are standards in place
to go meet specific criteria.
In the case of startups,
there's no such thing.
And I think there's
still a long way to go.
I think a lot of it comes from
just having channels, access
to other founders, mentors,
availability of board members
who are women.
Just opening up different
channels of communication,
I think there's a
long way to go there.
Any kind of access, supply--
conferences like this are great.
So I'm very optimistic
about how far we've come.
There's a long way to go.
Counterpoint to what Sowmya
was saying was for me
it's the fact that
we're still here,
and we're still talking
about diversity,
about how much we
have to go do tells us
that we're still not there.
And there's still
a long way to go.
YOLANDA MANGOLINI: Absolutely.
But it's nice that what we see
from optimism across the panel,
right?
That's sort of good news.
I spent the past seven years
trying to convince leaders
that having diverse teams can
improve bottom line results,
especially with regards
to creativity and design.
With mixed degrees of success.
Although I say by and
large, most leaders get it.
So I have a two part
question for any taker.
Do you personally
think this is true,
that having heterogeneous
teams lead to better results?
And the second part
of the question,
what are your best arguments
for building diverse teams?
AARTHI RAMAMURTHY:
I can go here.
For us, the way we
look at it is diversity
is important because you need
to reflect your customer base.
We deal with the
world of gadgets.
And traditionally, we've
been told, oh, gadgets,
consumer electronics,
it's all technophiles,
it's predominantly male.
When we first
launched, we realized
that for specific verticals
like fitness trackers,
it's predominantly female.
That's the use case.
And so we had to go back
to different manufacturers
and tell them, you
know, you're going
to have to design wearables that
are meant for a smaller wrist.
And we had to come up
with these suggestions
on who our target base and
who our customers were.
And I think having a
diverse team for us
to understand what was happening
and to reflect our customer
base was really helpful.
Which I don't think these
manufacturers and brands
necessarily did.
Or else they could have
caught this a lot sooner.
So for me, diversity
is about reflecting
your customer base is.
And making sure that you have
a similar kind of percentage
or set of people that your
target audience would also look
like.
That's kind of why I think
diversity is important.
It's not meant to be
let's hit this number,
let's check a check box.
It's not meant for that.
It's meant to go solve
a specific problem.
YOLANDA MANGOLINI: Are
there other examples
besides to reflect on user base
that you all have encountered?
JEANETTE CALANDRA: Yeah,
I mean, absolutely.
I don't think it's--
kind of pulling from
that point, right--
I don't think it's about putting
a bunch of diverse people
in a room, and that's going
to give you the solution.
Right?
It's really creating
the environment
through differentiated
leadership and coaching
and mentoring.
And being able to create that
safe environment for them
to be able to express
their point of view,
bring their perspectives.
And it was interesting, I
think early on in my career,
I figured this all out
a little bit by default.
We were in the middle of one
of the earlier financial crises
and regulatory reform.
And we had a lot of our clients
needing big, big projects,
with Sarbanes-Oxley,
trying to figure out
what they're doing with
their organization.
And somehow, I must have
stepped out for the day.
But when I came back to
try to put together a team,
all of our top
staff were already
assigned to the other leading
clients we were serving.
So really had to kind of
find creative ways to bring
other people in from other
countries, from other offices,
to put together this team.
And given the
backgrounds, I mean,
we hit every dimension of
diversity on this team.
And no one had the experience
of what we were doing.
So it was this interesting
experiment that said, look,
this is our team, we've
got to make it work.
And really got to understand
each of those individuals
to kind of pull out
their strengths.
And over the two year period,
it was just amazing what we saw.
And we drove so much
value for the clients.
And I think when I realized
that we were completely
validated was when I
got the call from HR,
and we had gone through
the performance cycle,
and they said why
are you hoarding
all the one rated staff.
Right?
And I said, that's
not how I started.
Right?
Nobody wanted pulling people
from different countries
and different backgrounds.
I mean, people had changed
careers and just got
into professional services.
But it took that team
working together.
So it was kind of that
a-ha moment for me
to say, OK, you have to work
a little bit differently
to bring out the
best in everyone.
You're not hiding
their differences.
You're really creating that
environment to promote them.
YOLANDA MANGOLINI: Absolutely.
BRIDGET FREY: And I really think
that high performing teams are
teams that are able to get a
lot of ideas onto the table,
and then figure out what
to do with those ideas.
There was some interesting
research into judges' panels.
Where when you
have three judges--
if you have just one that has a
different perspectives of, say,
two conservative judges
and one liberal judge,
the group will
make decisions that
are more towards the middle.
And those two conservative
judges, you know,
they could outvote everyone
else that's on the panel.
Why is it that they end
up being more moderate?
And it seems to be that
it's because they considered
another point of view.
And so having a diverse team is
one way to sort of manufacture
that concept of having lots
of ideas to choose from.
YOLANDA MANGOLINI: I love that.
I love that.
One of the of the moment
topics is intersectionality.
We're not one dimensional.
I'm a black woman.
I'm a mother.
I'm from the east coast.
I'm from a middle class family.
And we all bring our
intersectionality
in our lives as leaders.
What can we learn from
the multiple angles
and perspectives that we bring
to diversity and inclusion?
Again, any [INAUDIBLE],
any takers for that.
CAROLINE TSAY: Yeah.
I think one thing that comes
to mind for me personally
is age as well.
Sometimes it's a hard
topic to talk about
because you get into age
discrimination or things
like that.
But that's another
dimension in that
there's certain
experiences that come out
even at the board level of a lot
of public companies out there.
You typically have average
ages of 66 plus there.
And you've got so much diversity
of thought and experiences
coming in from different
generations and backgrounds
as a result of that.
But I think one
thing to really keep
in mind too is the culture,
the values that people have.
And it may be very
different for someone that
comes from another country.
Right?
At HP, we were very lucky
to hire a lot of folks
and have an h-1b
program that we put them
through right away, even
if they came in with a visa
and had several years into
getting through that visa.
And I think what
that taught me was
that there are so many ways
and perspectives and things
that people value.
Do they value relationships?
Do they value technology
and hard core experiences
and thought around
implementation of a product?
Versus something else.
And those things
start to come through
as you get that experience,
which I've been lucky to have.
And then you start
realizing that there's
so much more in the conversation
related to performance
management, objectives,
goals that people have,
that you want to keep in mind.
AARTHI RAMAMURTHY:
That makes sense.
For us, when we look at it,
one is the customer base,
user base, reflecting on that.
You're looking at the
immigrant population
making up for a huge
part of who we work with,
who our customers are,
who our neighbors are.
So it makes sense for us, for
our teams and our companies
to also reflect that.
And having this creative,
diverse mix of ideas is--
some of these, I would
have never thought about it
because I didn't
go through that.
I didn't study here, I didn't
have the same experience
as somebody else here.
So for me, it's
amazing to go work
with this diverse set of people.
It's very fulfilling,
and it's very gratifying
to be in that situation.
BRIDGET FREY: We
have some examples
where intersectional
teams have really helped
us to build better products.
So we are working
on a feature where
if you're trying
to buy a home, you
could invite other people
to help you with the search,
so to connect with other people.
And in some of the
original mocks,
they showed something
like invite your spouse
to this group.
And because we had an
intersectional team that
had women, LGBTQ, that
team looked at those mocks
and they said, hey, this
isn't inclusive language.
Instead, we should say
searching with someone else.
And I think at some point
in the product process,
maybe our customers would
have told us about it.
But how amazing is it to find it
so early in the design process.
And just show that
intersectional teams
can create better results.
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
Also, like, I
think a lot of this
discussion on diversity,
yes, it's about the team
and the team makeup.
It's also, I think, largely
about your growth strategy
for your product.
So many times, what
we see, look around--
and gadgets are a great example.
Including the Android Wear.
When it first came out, I
was like who designed this?
Now even if you
give it for free,
I'm not going to
wear this thing.
Even I'm from Google, and
it's not about our products.
It's an awesome product.
But why wouldn't you
have designed something
a little prettier or nicer.
Or something like that
fits a small wrist.
And it did change.
And we had those
internal discussions
when we broadened the team,
and started pointing out
this kind of feedback.
It's when we realized
actually we've completely
lost one kind of perspective
by focusing on maybe
the current dominant users.
So you go after the
current dominant users.
And you're a large--
most companies are
going in and saying,
I have these users who are
already engaged on my service.
And I'm going to try
and see how can I
get them hooked even more.
And continue to keep
moving that further.
So a lot of our machine learning
algorithms or designs or user
research ends up kind of fueling
that one dimensional thinking.
Which is an OK growth strategy.
But then there's this whole pie
of people you've unconsciously
left out on the table.
And if you just pause to
say, I unintentionally left
these people out, the
segment of the population.
So why didn't I think about what
would it take to bring them in?
You actually might have a
much larger, a much more
accelerated growth
plan than going
the route that you were going.
So for me, the whole discussion
about diversity-- yes,
it's about the funnel and
the team and all of that.
But at the end of the
day, it's not altruism.
Right?
It could be.
But there's actual-- and we
were talking with us last night
at the tech maker's
mixer, right--
it's about making
money and growth.
It really does affect
your bottom line.
BRIDGET FREY: I mean,
there's data out there
that demonstrates that.
And this is such a
data driven community.
So many organizations
including Catulus,
they crunch the
numbers when you look
at all these public
companies and the diversity
of their boards and
their leadership.
And you look at the difference
between those companies who
are the least diverse
in the lower quartile
and then those in the highest.
And the more diverse they are, I
mean whether you look at sales,
equity, return on
investment capital,
the difference is astronomical.
So you say, well, how are we
still in this conversation.
YOLANDA MANGOLINI:
Yes, absolutely.
So Jeanette, you've been
with PWC for 25 years,
as you mentioned.
So you've probably advised
hundreds of companies.
What's one of the
best examples you've
seen of a client where
diversity inclusion makes
a real impact on their
success and bottom line,
speaking of bottom line impact?
What can we learn from them?
JEANETTE CALANDRA: Absolutely.
I can definitely share
a story where I think we
as PWC learned from when
I-- when you saw what
was going on at the
client, and we kind of
changed our strategy
and approach.
So when I first came out
here, earlier in my career,
I got put on a team.
I'm serving one of the largest
well-known technology companies
out here in the valley.
And at that time, we maybe
had 20, 30 people service
serving this company.
And I was probably the most
diverse person of this team.
And going out there in the
meetings with their leadership,
there was just a
complete mismatch
when you looked at the
diverse backgrounds that
were coming to the table
to discuss a business
issue or a problem, versus what
we were bringing to the table.
And for I would say many
years, our relationship
was fairly stagnant.
And then I had the opportunity
to step into the lead partner
role.
And said, OK,
strategically, we're
going to do this all different.
I need to kind of bring in
not only the best talent,
but think about
those diverse views
that are going to really
resonate with our customer.
And so slowly
transitioned our team
to bring in a new set
of eyes, if you would.
And the results were magical.
I mean, I love showing
the 10 year graph
of the success of this account.
I mean for so long,
it was like this.
And all of a sudden when we
made that shift in the team
and worked differently
with our customer, I mean,
it went straight up like that.
And you say, what happened here?
Like, we got more diverse.
I love this.
All right.
So again, I kind of want to
tie in to one other point
that we haven't touched upon.
I love-- I don't
know if any of you
had read Pat Wadors' article
in the Harvard Business Review.
She is the CHRO of LinkedIn.
And so she goes one step further
beyond-- she calls it dibs.
You've got diversity,
inclusion, and then belonging.
And belonging being that feeling
of that part of that team being
valued is such a
critical part of creating
that optimal performing team.
And so that has always
been a main tenet
kind of looking at our clients
who've done it really well.
They've created that belonging.
And how do we bring that into
how we're working with them.
YOLANDA MANGOLINI: Absolutely.
So Caroline, you've led teams
at large enterprises, HP
and Yahoo, for example.
And at startups and
early stage companies.
Generally speaking,
do you think startups
slash early stage companies or
more established tech companies
are better at putting
diversity at the center
of their business?
And can you contrast
your experiences
having been at both.
CAROLINE TSAY:
Well, so it depends
on what you mean by startup.
Startup could be
one person or it
could be thousands of people.
Startup is a big range.
I will say, though,
that in general, what I
got to see out of HP and Yahoo
is that the companies have
resources to invest
and spend time,
through the HR function
and organization,
through teaching and
coaching, the leadership
and the management, to
invest in building up
pipelines of candidates
from other places.
Whereas, you know, when
you're in a startup,
it's like go, go, go, go, go.
You just don't
think about anything
except finding somebody
through your connection
as quickly as you can,
getting that introduction.
And then very
quickly, you're kind
of narrowing the pie
of opportunities or way
you're thinking about this.
Also with a lot of larger
enterprises or bigger
companies, they can
invest in h-1b visas,
I mentioned, or visas,
and funding that.
Or relocating people from
other locations, which I think
is incredibly powerful.
Because you just get
so much diversity of
thought in the ways
that I mentioned,
and the values and
kind of the thinking.
So you know, I think about that.
But I highly encourage,
even for small companies--
I've seen too many kind of
smaller companies, startups,
maybe a few people
who've been working
with each other for a long time,
who tend to talk or say things
that are like, oh my gosh,
wait till you go hire
that first woman into
the organization,
or first other person that is
very different from you guys.
I mean that very generically.
We've got to think about
putting in place programs
to be more thoughtful
about this.
So I do see quite a
bit of differences
when it comes to
larger, more established
companies, the resources
they have to bring to bear,
the way they're
thinking about this.
Versus startups that generally
are more into this go,
go, go, mentality.
YOLANDA MANGOLINI: It's
an interesting tension,
because you would argue that
it's much-- particularly
from a representation
point of view--
it's much easier if you start
when you're smaller than when
you're a 65,000 person company.
But it's a really great
point about the resources.
Bridget.
So you got an early start
with computer programming.
And you programmed
an Apple computer,
and that brings me back.
So it's something that many
girls don't get a chance to do.
Do you think the tech
industry is doing enough
to attract girls into our ranks?
And is it better or worse
now than 10 years ago?
BRIDGET FREY: Yeah.
So I got my start with
computers when I was five.
My dad is an appliance
sales and repairmen.
And so when I was five,
he bought an Apple IIe.
And to him it was just
like another machine.
It was like a dishwasher.
You get the manual, you figure
out how that thing works.
And that's what
the two of us did.
And so by the time I started
getting messages from society
that, you know, tech
wasn't for girls,
I already loved computers.
So I was able to get
through that phase.
But there are so many girls
for whom they're not getting
those really early experiences.
And so I start to
shift to those messages
that society is giving them.
And that's why I appreciate
work that Sowmya and her team
and others are
doing, to look at how
the media is portraying things.
That it can be funny to talk
about the lonely, bedraggled
engineer working by themselves.
And you know, we're
all chuckling about it.
Or is it really funny?
Or is it actually just
kind of a disturbing way
to perpetuate these stereotypes
that keep people out?
YOLANDA MANGOLINI:
So related, so
Sowmya, you lead a huge
part of YouTube's efforts
to empower women
and girls, and you
mentioned that in your intro.
What can everyone here learn
about YouTube's efforts here?
And what lessons can folks
take away and bring back
to their companies?
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: Yeah I think
your point that you brought up,
which is once you become
big, changing the numbers,
even though you have so
many resources, it's harder,
it's very, very real.
I think there are
challenges on both sides,
whether you're a small or
you're resource constrained,
and you're just taking
what are you get.
Right?
Not whatever, but
what quality bars.
Or you're big.
And one of the things I
think we've done really
well in Google and
YouTube as a whole
is not be afraid to
question the status quo.
So we really do look at data.
And we also look at the
processes that we have.
And ask whether
things are working
because they were
working in the past,
or is there a
better way to do it.
So an example is--
and this is an example
outside of Google,
but I use it within Google
to drive change with our HR
and process organizations--
Maria Klawe, I don't know how
many people have heard of her.
She's the Dean of
Harvey Mudd College.
And she came from Yale, where
she was heading up the computer
science department.
And several years ago, I think
when she took on that role
in Harvey Mudd, she
decided that it's
going to be her mission in life
to change the number of girls
entering into the
computer science program,
and women graduating
from her program.
And she approached it
less about is there
a funnel problem, do I need to
encourage more girls and women.
She decoded it as,
she just observed
that a lot of the
entering class women
were not even signing up for
their introductory computer
science classes.
Because the way
it was structured
and the way it was
presented was alienating.
Many of the incoming
men in the class
somehow had had
computer exposure
already by the time they
came to college compared
to the women, for some reason.
And the way the programming
assignments and everything is--
the way that the course
was being pitched
was set the bar so high that
people were just afraid,
saying, this is not for me.
So she redid the
whole curriculum.
And I think they don't call
them by numbers anymore.
They do like bronze,
gold, silver levels.
And she really made the
introductory levels fun,
and a lot of team
activities, and much more
of a gentler introduction into
the field to build confidence.
And what she started seeing
is more women actually realize
that not only do they enjoy it,
they're also really good at it.
And they should be considering
this more seriously.
So did she change the
bar of her program?
No, she did not.
But she just restructured it
to make it more appealing.
And now, I think,
as of last year
they have a 50/50 graduating
class of men and women
for the computer
science program.
Which is a huge
change to bring about
in a few year time period.
So I think for
companies like Google,
because we have the
resources, the opportunity--
and we do use the opportunity,
actually, we've done this--
is look at how your
promotion process works.
Look at how performance
evaluations are done.
Look at how
interviewing is done.
And see, are there things
that we could be changing
to make it more inclusive.
So one of the things Google
did several years ago
is the interview
panels, they make
sure there's at least
one woman on the panel.
They make sure it's a diverse
group of interviewers.
Not just for the female
candidates, but all candidates.
So you get a diverse
perspective on this person,
rather than this one
kind of, like, I'm just
projecting myself on everyone.
So yeah, I think
there are things
we've done that are working.
YOLANDA MANGOLINI:
They've very powerful.
I agree, having
been in that space.
Aarthi, so you were
quoted in Business Insider
that your time at
Microsoft inspired
you to build a
business that would
cater to millions of people.
And your time at
Netflix taught you
how to create a
healthy team dynamic.
How did diversity play
into those experiences?
And what are the most
important learnings
that you brought to Lumoid?
AARTHI RAMAMURTHY: Yeah.
You know how-- it might not
apply to you on a day to day
basis, but every
once in a while,
you'll have one of those
days where you'd be like,
if I did this on my own, I
would do things differently.
If only I could do this my
way, I would do it differently.
Well, now I can.
And it's incredible
to have that feeling.
And startups are not easy.
I don't mean to say
that they're simple.
They're really hard.
This is the hardest
thing I've ever done.
But with respect to
diversity and inclusion,
there is so much freedom to
go do tests and experiments.
And really prove out that
you're not doing this just
for the sake of it.
And it's actually profitable.
You're leaving
money on the table
if you're not
considering diversity.
And being able to think about
it with a very data-centric,
result-centric approach
has been really great.
Even though, you know,
ours is a small company,
we're about 40 people.
So it's nowhere the size
of Microsoft or Netflix.
But we're able to think about it
in a much more independent way.
And that's been
incredible for us
as we grow and scale the
culture of the company.
Because in the future, when
we have directors and managers
within the company, we want
them to think about this
as I'm not doing this just
to go fill out this form
and make sure that
there's diversity.
But I'm doing this because
this is the right business
decision for the company.
This is how I want to
think about the future.
And similar to Bridget, I
think, I started writing code
when I was 12.
Started getting
into Common-Lisp--
I don't even know if anyone
knows the language here.
And started writing
my own interpreter.
And by the time people
started saying, oh, it's
not meant for women,
it was too late.
You already have me.
Too bad, can't do
anything about it.
So it's about getting
the right set of people.
And for a startup, I
think you do whatever it
takes to find the right person.
It's usually through
personal networks.
And it turns out that I'm
a diverse person, just
a background and
where I come from.
And so my team is
extremely diverse.
We have people from
all over the world.
And it's great.
It's working out really well.
And we have arguments
on how things should go
and how things should work.
But it's never in the context
of I don't really know,
let's just do this
kind of thing.
But it's more like
where I come from,
this is how we've
done it kind of thing.
And it's a really
nice place to be.
There's a long way
to go for all of us.
But proving to yourself that
diversity works is the number
one thing, it's
the simplest thing
that you can do instead
of just going with they
said we have to
have diverse people,
so let's focus on diversity.
You need to test it out
for yourself to make sure
that you know that it works.
YOLANDA MANGOLINI: So one
last question for you all
before we open it
up to the audience.
So start thinking
about your questions.
Each of you have risen to
the top of your industry
which is not an easy task
for a man, let alone a woman.
When we know all the systemic
biases and structural biases
that exist.
So I'd love to hear, and
I'm sure the audience would
love to hear a little
bit from each of you
about your own journey.
What barriers have you had
to overcome, and specifically
as a woman in
technology, to succeed.
BRIDGET FREY: Well,
one thing that Jeanette
touched on a little
is just how we make
tech inclusive for parents.
So I have two boys.
I think a number of our
panelists also have children.
And how do you negotiate that
part of your career, I think,
is something that tech
could really get better.
When I joined Redfin, I
already had two children.
And I felt lucky that I had
known the CEO for a long time,
for many years.
And he was willing
to sit down with me
and have a really direct
conversation about what I
needed, what types
of hours, about how
I would preserve that family
time in the evening that
was so important to me.
And we were able to
figure out something
that worked for both of us.
And it was so important
during those years.
So for anyone who's
a manager out there
or someone who's
working with people
who are going to be parents
or have leaves coming up,
I would ask you to
focus more on what
it's going to be like for that
person when they come back.
There's so much focus
on when the person's
going to be out for a few
weeks or a few months.
But that's not the issue.
The issue is how are you going
to support that employee when
they get back, and when their
kids' needs are changing
over time.
JEANETTE CALANDRA: So when
I think about the barriers--
and they started from
even before I embarked
on my career--
you wonder how sometimes you
got you got where you got to.
And kind of to share one
of the earliest stories,
so I was a math and numbers
geek when I was a teenager.
So very early on,
I had a passion
for what I wanted to do.
And I remember the
time very vividly
that I was babysitting
for this local family.
And the dad of the family,
he owned his own CPA firm.
So when I came to
this realization
that this is the path
of accountancy I wanted
to go down, I just remember
coming home one night,
he was driving me
back to my house.
And I was so excited to
share, kind of I figured out--
you know, everyone
asks you, what do
you do when you grow up, right.
So I finally figured this out.
And so I broke the
news in the car.
I mean, he literally stopped the
car, pulled over to the side.
And looked at me and
he goes, why would you
do something stupid like that?
Women are not going to be
successful in accounting
or business.
And just like hung
there in the car.
And so I was kind of one
of these pivotal moments.
And you could either
have taken that
and gone down a different path.
Or it just created
this passion in me,
like I'm going to
prove him wrong.
Let me keep on going
down this journey.
And I think I had a
number of those times
throughout my career where
there's a lot of support,
but other times where you get
this reaction from someone,
where you're really
surprised at that reaction.
And I guess the
advice I would say
is you've got to look
past the statistics,
and push through it.
Because you got to be part of
the effort to make that change.
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: Yeah, mine
is very different actually.
So my mom is a math teacher.
And I grew up always kind of
enjoying math and the numbers.
And I never really defined
myself by my gender,
that I can do this or not do it.
And I think the barriers
are more subtle in my world.
Because I always had the support
of my family to be a computer
science engineer.
I started out as
an engineer too.
Had been exposed to computers
at a very early age.
There was never really a
barrier because I was a woman
until, I think, I started work.
And even at work, it was less
about someone's telling you not
to do it because you're a
woman, to not just seeing people
around you who are like you.
So I still remember, I was
an intern at this company.
And one of these really
senior engineers, and he
was very well respected
in the company,
and he's a great friend now.
But at that time, he happened
to run into me at lunch.
And he said, he was asking
me, oh, you're an intern.
And he kept talking
to me, all along,
assuming I was a marketing
intern for some reason.
And then as we were walking
back, he saw me go to the floor
where all the database
engineers were.
We were building the
database systems.
And he was like, why
are you coming here?
Are you following me?
I said no, I'm
going to my office.
And he said, oh, you code.
And the surprise on his
face was kind of like--
It's many times,
you know, I went
to undergrad at Mount
Holyoke College.
And I was an international
student there.
And the international
orientation,
they told us, many people
might come and tell you
you speak really good English.
And you should thank them,
and use it as an opportunity
to correct the
ignorance, and say
English was my first
language growing up.
Like why would I not
speak good English?
So I did the same
thing with this guy.
Just told him, ha, you know, I
am a computer science student
like anyone else from the
University of Wisconsin
Madison.
Why shouldn't I code?
And then he was like, oh, OK.
And he just walked away.
He didn't know what to say.
And then later he
came back and told me,
I was looking at all the
code you were writing,
you know, your CLs and
they're pretty good.
They're really good.
And that was a shift, right?
So I think in my case of
barriers-- and along the way,
even now sometimes you
are like the minority
voice in the group,
kind of shifting people.
And knowing not to doubt
yourself or your confidence,
but use it in a very
practical way as to say,
if you believe this
is the way to go,
or if you believe you have the
right skills, just push for it,
and make it happen.
I think that's kind
of my barriers story.
More than like an explicit
barrier that I had to overcome.
YOLANDA MANGOLINI:
That's powerful.
Caroline.
CAROLINE TSAY: So since
we're talking about a few
growing up stories,
I was actually
told that I had to do
electrical engineering
or that my tuition
wouldn't get paid for.
So I tried to look at e.
And then I actually
thought, OK, well,
maybe if I go to CS, that won't
be too far of a departure.
And I will still get
my tuition paid for.
So I actually ended up
taking my first CS class.
I think what was so
powerful, so gratifying is
that when you're coding, you
can see the immediate results
of what you're doing.
Versus maybe some hardware
initiatives or projects,
it takes a little bit
longer to get there.
So I ended up doing
CS in undergrad.
I've always stayed
in tech in my career.
And I think one
of the challenges
that I've always had
to really think about
as I've progressed in my
career is how much do you
decide when you want to fit
in, to be like everyone else,
so that it feels
OK to everybody.
You don't stand out in some way.
And I mean this
in a way that you
dress, the way that you
communicate, the way that you
talk, the way that you present
yourself, the way that you
put on makeup or not.
I mean, seriously,
down to that level.
I've had to think about
that through my career.
I think at the end
of the day, though,
when you can think about your
strengths, what you bring
to the table, and you've
got confidence around
that, all of those things
don't matter so much anymore.
But there is a
bit of a fine line
in thinking about
when you fit in,
when you might not, that
I've had to really go through
in my career.
AARTHI RAMAMURTHY: I feel myself
vehemently agreeing and nodding
to everyone here.
Because I feel like
this is a first-- like I
do a few of these panels.
This is the first time I
feel like, oh my god, they're
speaking my story.
And what Sowmya said,
what Bridget said,
it's just like it's insane
that all of us go through this.
And you know, these are
still pretty serious issues.
I mean, I graduated 10
years ago, multiple jobs,
and you still see this
on a day to day basis.
And when I graduated, master's
in software engineering,
I think my graduating
class had 60% women.
And for me, honestly,
coming from India to here,
being in India, it didn't
feel like this odd thing.
It was like, yeah, that's
kind of what you do.
You get a job.
You write code,
great, good for you.
And you just move on.
But when I came here they
were like oh, you write code.
Are you sure?
And I'm like, yes, I'm sure.
What kind of a question is that.
How do I tell you if I'm
like 100% sure or 80% sure?
It's just this
ridiculous sense of what
you have to think about,
how you have to communicate.
You can't really
snap at them, you
have to be patient with them.
And you're like, you
go through all of this.
In your mind, you just run
this whole flowchart of stuff.
And you're like, not worth it.
You know what, just move on.
And I feel like all of us
have been through that.
And everything from graduation
to being in a team where I
think I was one of three women.
And the weirdest were
these happy hours.
And you're like, what do you do?
Like especially if one or
two women don't show up
and you're the odd person out.
You're just like looking at
each other like am I being here,
like, this is odd
for you people?
Or is this the other way around?
What do you do?
So you have all these
like semi funny stories.
And semi oh my god,
this is really sad.
And I get it, this
is kind of how it is.
There's so few women
in computer science
and in engineering and tech, and
we're working on changing that.
But today, right now, it's 6:00
p.m., and this is where we are,
and this is what we're doing.
And I think you go
through that from there
to building your
own startup, you
see a totally different
set of challenges.
Which is fundraising.
Most investors don't
really see female CEOs.
And when you go into
pitch, they're like, oh,
so where's the founder.
And you're like, well,
you're speaking to her.
I'm sorry but it's
me, you just have me.
And they're like, OK,
so where's the coding
guy, like, the engineering guy.
And you're like uh, me, sorry.
And you're constantly
apologizing.
And you're like, why
am I apologizing?
I'm just as good as
like other people here.
But you go through a
lot of this in your--
it's come to a point where
I'm not cynical or jaded.
But you just accept
that there is
going to be this level of
people always not really
knowing what you really do.
So now my job is to clearly
go out and establish
and communicate what I
do, and where I come from,
and this is how it is, and
this is the reality of what we
are doing, this is our startup.
And we get these assumptions
made all the time.
And it is a challenge.
It's not easy.
But it's getting
a little better.
I mean, the more we do
stuff like this, the more--
you know, you pulled out this
piece from Business Insider.
And I was like, hey,
somebody has read that.
It's great.
So it's changing.
Things are changing.
And it's all getting better.
But some of these, you're
going to hear for a while.
You're going to hear
these stories, which
are like half amusing.
And there is-- I will tell you,
there are groups of women who
will sit around and talk
about this and be like,
do you remember that
time when this happened,
and we just laugh about it.
But it's also kind of sad.
And we'll commiserate.
And it's nice to have a
group of women who do that.
And it's nice to see men
here, who are a part of this.
And you're not ignoring
this whole thing.
And these are challenges.
And we will get
through all of them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]